bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rtl
rt france très concrètement quel danger
selon vous pèse sur les journalistes
avec ces deux articles de loi tout
d'abord on est heureux de voir que rsf
rejoint un combat que nous menons depuis
le 10 novembre contre la proposition de
loi sécurité globale qui effectivement
porte en son sein un certain nombre
d'articles est extrêmement attentatoires
aux libertés fondamentales de la france
dans cet article 24 que précisément
comme dans l'article 18 de la loi
séparatisme
il est prévu que des entraves peut
apporter à la diffusion d'image etc etc
si c'était fait dans une intention
malveillante
ce qui signifie de la censure et
l'autocensure direct pour deux raisons
la première c'est que vous avez dès lors
de manifestations et lors d'actions du
maintien de l'ordre
le droit et le devoir pour tous les
journalistes de témoigner de ce qui se
passe dans le pays
or ceci pourra les empêcher de le faire
par censure ou par autocensure par
censure parce que les forces de l'ordre
seraient alors juge et partie en même
temps et pourrait saisir les caméras ou
interdire de prendre quelques photos que
ce soit je rappelle simplement que c'est
grâce à ces témoignages vidéos photos
que les plus grosses affaires de
mensonges qui ont entraîné un parfois
des morts et souvent des blessés graves
dans la population civile
donc cause les mensonges de certaines
parties des forces de l'ordre dont
étaient démontés vous avez le sentiment
qu'il ya aujourd'hui une réelle
intention s'attarder sur l'activité des
journalistes d'écouté s'il n'y a pas eu
de réelles intentions franchement ce
serait un prétendant de ne pas
l'imaginer car sans avoir de la paranoïa
dans nos gènes il faut bien reconnaître
qu'entre le schéma national du maintien
de l'ordre qui voudrait consacrer dit
avant chaque manifestation bien
gentiment auprès du préfet entre les
décrets
du 2 décembre 2020 qui portent atteinte
directement à la protection des sources
des journalistes qui porte sur le fait
de recueillir des avis politiques et
syndicaux donc nous sommes à doublement
à double titre concerné si on n'avait
pas la paranoïa dans les gènes on
finirait par l'acquérir donc bien
évidemment toutes ces mesures qui sont
stigmatisés par toutes les instances
internationales et françaises sont des
mesures liberticides pour la liberté
d'informer et d'être informé des par les
citoyens pour lire sur le communiqué de
rsf à l'association estime qu'il faut
davantage lutter contre la diffusion
notamment sur internet d'informations
personnelles ou qui permettent
l'identification des personnes dans le
but de leur nuire elle prend pour
exemple notamment samuel pâtissait aussi
votre heure ressentiez à écouter toutes
les
tous les textes qui ont essayé de près
ou de loin de cerner les difficultés sur
internet sont vains si on ne dit pas que
les réseaux sociaux qui sont en france
ont les mêmes types de responsabilité
que les médias on va être clair c'est à
dire des responsabilités juridiques tout
simplement
et quant au fait d'appeler à les
surveiller
c'est très bien la plateforme pharos qui
la plateforme des policiers chargés de
surveiller est un sous développement en
effectifs et en moyens et là on se
demande bien pourquoi puisque avec des
moyens et un effectif correct qui
pourrait faire un travail bien amélioré
enfin il ya un alibi contre les
journalistes les cinéaste et
documentariste et les citoyens de dire
il faut protéger les policiers aucun
exemple aucun exemple ne nous a été
fournie jusqu'à présent de difficultés
qu est une dépense de l'ordre du fait
des journalistes est-ce qu'elle serait
plutôt ce qui serait envisageable plutôt
que d'ajouter 2
de nouvelles lois de compléter plus tôt
la loi de 1881 bah écoutez nous au pire
du pire si la loi ppl sécurité globale
devait passer ces 10 propose tout
simplement de la rédiger ainsi les
policiers ne bénéficient pas de
protection particulière etc
il ya deux encadrés qui ouvrait la
directive du ministère de l'intérieur
c'est pas une directive du snj c'est une
directive du ministère de l'intérieur du
23 décembre 2008 et qui prouve qu'ils
disent que les journalistes et des
citoyens ont le droit de prendre en
photos ou de filmer les forces de
l'ordre et cet article 24 donc ci
devrait reprendre ses deux principaux
points et ajouté que sera puni d'une
amende ou d'emprisonnement et c'est à
toute personne qui contreviendrait aux
dispositions dudit article merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de réagir
sur notre antenne dominicain pradal et
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général du snj